welcome to this video on playing fish
puppy fish puppy from the US and we got
to the only hands with b6 interesting
I'm not shown Queenie to pure probably
yeah there's this stuff like knight c6
in this kind of positions attacking d4
and impossible night before ok so we
transpose and joy but this is pin as a
Solian type of position in case I allow
him to take but I can also go here and
this one shuts down the b7 Bishop if he
takes i retake on d5 with a check and
then i have time to place you form to
fix the pawn on d5 or support the corner
it was the wrong word Gaston we should
do that if he allows me to play see 493
I just have an excellent yeah he just
did that an excellent type of benoni mmm
Jim is this even the possibility to play
Bishop b5 him try to play on the light
squares
yeah I wonder if I shut them maybe just
just Castle castles he simply does not
react to all this okay John I'm going to
try to play em more directly could have
firm played in a more restrained fashion
with c4 which basically secures a
long-term edge and this tries to play
more directly I think yeah he needed to
take on f3 now I'm threatening to take
on these seven i drugged you hooked you
I don't understand ok this is also
winning a piece check black resides yeah
what again yeah at least them I'm glad
to have this kind of game once in a
while if I start a session or when I
start a session simply because it helps
you to get warmed up I tried to play
less of these prep games where I
constantly lose anyway okay I'm but
let's quickly check what happened here
I'm not sure about the third is opening
line after d5 it seems to me that white
is already much better the problem is
from a strategical point of view that I
will place afford to support the porn
and let's say for example something like
that Queenie 7 i'm playing see for now
and he's got problems with b7 this is
bishop is always biting on this d5 pawn
and the structure with the space
advantage is better for white anyway so
it's very tricky I don't know I did I
think he pretends to take and now yeah
yeah there's even a quick rookie one
know if he plays something like this so
I'm trying to say something like this
this is very very problematic yeah the
computer actually gives white already a
winning edge the Sun is a bit much maybe
but why this cell substantially better
young and if he plays a move like like
he did in the game I have a very nice
choice i can just place he fall and get
this good structure again with the bed
bishop on b7 or when i tried was first
castling okay now i could play a five to
shut the position down but he played
this and yeah now we have this yeah yeah
here 95 was even stronger this is bad i
should have played that yeah okay my bad
plan was to play if I wish I'd which I
did and here I thought he must take on
f3 this kind of any position I mean why
does obviously in excellent shape but
because uh well I'm pinning this on all
all in all possible ways um yeah I don't
know if he if he cancels for example
yeah Black is basically lost him and
then after that yeah it its deadly on d
7 I just I saw was surprised that he
played this so quickly because well
check this is very obvious loss getting
getting the night yeah I don't don't
really think that c5 is appropriate him
probably um oops something too quick
probably and black should should play
play d5
oh yeah probably something like that
it's tricky anyway this is just not a
good opening I mean it should be
playable but like you shouldn't equalize
really alright thanks for watching